SPEAKER 1: Please help me
welcome to the stage Tara Mohr.
TARA MOHR: Yeah.
Thank you.
Thank you for having me.
Everybody can hear me OK?
Great.
I'm so happy to be here.
This is the neck of the woods
where I grew up, actually.
So nice to be back
down on the peninsula.
And I'm really thrilled to
be talking with all of you
about women playing big,
how we end up playing small,
and how we can play bigger.
And I want to begin by
sharing with you why I started
doing this work and
how I came to be
thinking about these topics.
About 10 years
ago, I was starting
to make a big transition
in my own career.
I had identified
that I didn't really
love the work I was doing.
And I wanted to
be doing work that
dealt with people's
inner lives and helping
them create the lives and
careers they really wanted.
And I didn't know exactly
what that would look like.
But I thought coaching would
have something to do with it.
And so I had gotten
trained as a coach.
And while I was still
working full-time
in another job during the
evenings and the weekends,
I was squeezing in this
exploration of this new area
and starting to
coach mostly friends
of friends and
colleagues of colleagues
who had heard I was
exploring coaching
and starting a little
coaching practice.
And most of the women that
came to that practice I
had the exact same response to.
I would sit across from these
women in a coaching session
and get to hear about their
dreams, what they wanted
for their careers, what
they saw that was happening
in their company or
their organization
that they had a critique of or
a better vision for what they
thought their
industry was missing.
I got to hear all of
these amazing reflections
of their insights
and their brilliance.
And I just became so inspired
by every single one of them.
By the ideas they had,
by their thoughtfulness,
by how ethical and conscientious
they were in their approach
to their work.
And so I just wanted
to see them leading
and having more influence
and power in our world.
And yet over and
over and over again
I heard the same
things from them.
I'm not ready yet to
take that next step.
I probably need
more training first.
I need a few more
years experience.
Don't I need another degree?
If that was a good
idea, someone would
have thought of it already.
Let me think about that more
and do more research on it
before I do anything about it.
And I started to
feel really pained
by this, because as we all know,
we look in the news headlines
or we see the decisions that
are being made by people
in leadership, and
we know that seems
like our world deserves better.
And here I was sitting
across from these women.
And I thought this is the
better that we deserve.
And yet it's somehow not--
that brilliance isn't really
making it to the seats of power
and the places of influence
where it deserves to be.
And so that phenomenon--
that gap between potential
and how people saw themselves
I needed a shorthand way
to label.
And "playing small" seemed
like a good term for it.
At about the same
time, I had started
blogging about
personal growth topics
and professional
development topics.
And a few years into blogging,
my readership had grown.
And I got very curious to learn
more about who was reading
and why.
And so I sent out a
survey to my readers.
And in the survey,
one of the questions
was, what's the biggest
challenge in your life?
Right.
Probably many of you
know from your work,
that's a great market
research question.
You want to know what
are people feeling pained
by and challenged by.
And knowing that most of
my readers were women,
I had this list of options
on the multiple choice survey
of things I thought
might be the biggest
challenge in their life.
So of course, I put
work/family balance on there,
because that's what everybody
talks about as a huge challenge
in women's lives.
I put health issues up
there, and financial issues,
relationship challenges.
I'm not sure what I
want, a whole host
of things from different
domains of life.
Then I looked at that
list and I thought,
there's actually
nothing on that list
that reflects what I'm hearing
from women in my coaching
practice.
And so kind of on
a whim I added,
"I'm playing small" as
a possible challenge
that people could choose.
And when the
responses came back,
that was what the
most women said
was the biggest
challenge in their life.
I'm playing small.
And that was so striking
to me that so many of us
are walking around with some
sense that we're playing small.
And we feel challenged
by it, meaning
we must somehow be stuck there.
We don't know how to
fix that or change it.
And so that became the
focus of my work-- trying
to understand why
are we playing small,
and then most importantly,
what really makes a difference.
What makes a difference so we
stop saying, I'm not ready yet,
we stop saying I need
more qualifications,
we start sharing more of
ourselves more bravely.
And I found through
my coaching practice
that there really were some
tools and some new pieces
of knowledge, and some
everyday moment-to-moment
practices we could do
that produced really
big change for people quite
consistently, whether they were
in a junior or senior
level of their career,
whether they were working in
business or the social sector,
whether they were entrepreneurs
or inside a large organization.
The fundamentals of change that
needed to happen were the same.
And those fundamentals
became the basis for the work
that I now do for leadership
trainings, for the book.
And we're going
to talk about some
of the key pieces of that today.
Before we jump into that,
there is one important thing
I want to address.
Because we are going
to be talking today
about the inner barriers
for women around our playing
bigger.
And it can be easy for that
to be misconstrued as then
that disparity that we see
in leadership, the challenges
that women face are inside
us all our own fault. Right?
And I certainly don't want
to convey that in any way.
So first I want
to give voice to,
of course there are
huge external barriers.
Many of which I am sure
through the Women at Google
work you're learning about
here all kinds of bias,
and implicit and explicit
discrimination, the pay gap,
and so on.
Right?
And there are
these inner issues.
And the inner
barriers that we face,
the kind of playing
small and talking about I
don't see it as disconnected
from those external barriers
at all.
So we didn't just make
this up because we
thought it would be great to
play small and hold ourselves
back.
But rather that if
you think about what
it means to be a woman
in our time right now,
we are in this amazing
transitional moment in history.
We're coming out of thousands
of years of a legacy
where women were pretty
much marginalized entirely
from professional life,
political life, public life.
And the legacy of that--
the residue of that--
is still so alive in our culture
in many ways, in our media.
It's so alive in the
messages we get at school
and often at home, as well.
And that has certain effects
on how we see ourselves
and how we behave.
And so when we talk
about the inner barriers,
we're really talking about the
inner imprint of that legacy
and of that culture.
OK.
So with that, let's jump in.
We'll talk about
three areas today
where I commonly see so many
women holding themselves back,
and where we can make really
transformative change.
And the first one is
our inner critics.
So anyone have one of these?
Yes.
Two hands.
Two hands go up.
Yeah.
Anyone feel like you don't have
an inner critic that you're
burdened by or
affected by as you move
through your life or your work?
OK.
Yeah.
So most of us are aware that we
do have this voice in our head
that says not very nice things
to us about ourselves that
voices a lot of self-doubt.
And as much as
we're aware of it,
we also probably don't even
notice-- for most of us
we don't even notice
about 90% of what
it's saying, because
it's become so habitual.
It's the water that we swim in.
So that oh, I'm just not good
at that whole set of things.
Oh, there's no way I could
be the person to do that.
Things that maybe we just
feel like that's true about us
or that's our way of thinking
is often the inner critic.
So the first piece
of work we need to do
is start to recognize when
am I hearing my inner critic.
And start to notice that
as a voice in our heads,
not just how my thinking
sounds, not just that's
who I am, but start to
notice it as one voice
so that over time we can
get connected to some
of the other voices
inside of us.
So how do we recognize it?
We listen for when do you hear
a voice talking to you in a way
that you would not intend
to talk to someone you love?
When do you hear the voice
of I'm not ready yet?
That's usually
your inner critic.
For women, interestingly,
there is really
not good research that says we
have more self-doubt than men.
That's a common
misunderstanding.
But there is data that suggests
women do feel more self-doubt
than men around those things
that are traditionally
associated with
masculinity in our culture.
So that's quantitative work,
financial work and decisions,
negotiation, and leadership.
There we see that
women tend to have
more self-doubt about themselves
in those areas of skill
and work.
On the other side
of the coin, there's
some data that
suggests that men feel
more self-doubt around
emotional and relational skills
like listening,
reading nonverbal cues,
and communication.
So our self-doubt, of
course, is showing up
in what's been
conditioned in our culture
to have us think it's associated
with us or people like us.
So listen.
Particularly when do you
notice that voice of,
I'm just not good at
those kinds of things.
That's your inner critic.
You might notice your inner
critic is often also for women
the voice of body perfectionism
or self-consciousness
around our bodies.
It tends to be a very
repetitive, broken record
kind of voice.
And it may take some cues from
outer critics in your life.
Right?
So you might notice, oh, that
inner critic voice is saying
a lot of things that when I
really think about it, that
sounds like an internalized
voice of that really
tough first boss I had, or that
professor who delivered that
really, really harsh feedback,
or that person in my childhood
who was very critical of me.
But that's not
true for everyone.
You don't have to find
an external source
for your critic.
You might just notice
some echoes there.
So starting to
notice that voice.
A question I get a lot around
noticing the inner critic
is what's the difference
between the inner critic
and realistic thinking?
Right.
There's good critical thinking
that might realistically
assess something and come back
with yeah, it's not that good.
You're not ready yet.
I'm not good at that, right?
So how do we know
when we're hearing
that more irrational
inner critic
versus realistic thinking?
And the way you can
tell the difference
there is really the tone of
the thoughts in your head.
It's not even a distinction
of what those two voices say.
They might have
the same concerns.
I'm not sure you're ready for
that stretch assignment yet.
But the way they talk to
you about those concerns
will be very different.
So the inner critic will sound
more anxious, more chattery,
more repetitive.
I'm not sure if I'm ready.
I really don't think
I could do that.
What if this worst-case
scenario happens.
More fearful about
future consequences.
And you'll notice that if
it's your inner critic,
it's not trying to move
towards any solution
or resolution of the problem.
Realistic thinking
might say, you
know, I am not
sure if I am ready,
if I have what I need to
take that stretch assignment.
How can I find that out?
Who could I talk to?
How can I evaluate it?
How can I test it?
Is there a low-risk
way to do it?
Let's think through
what would be the worst
thing that could happen.
So you can hear the tone.
Realistic thinking is curious.
It's generative.
And it's on your side.
It moves forward down
a path of reasoning,
whereas your inner critic
is going to loop and loop
and loop.
So why do we have
this inner critic?
What is it?
A mistake that I
think a lot of us
make-- and I used to
share this misconception--
is that if we're not confident,
if we feel a lot of self-doubt,
one, that's a personal
problem-- something missing
from us as individuals.
And two, somehow if we
look back into our history,
we can find the reason for it.
Was it that I never learned to
develop enough confidence doing
competitive things as a kid?
Was it these critical
people in my life?
Was it that my parents
were so supportive of me
that now the world feels
really dangerous and scary
in contrast, and everything
feels so critical?
We look to our
biography for some sort
of reason for that self-doubt.
And after talking to so many
women about their inner critics
and really digging into the
mechanics of self-doubt,
I can say that that's not
the place to find the answer.
There's nothing in
your life experience
that is responsible
for self-doubt.
That in fact, we're all
hardwired-- we're all
hardwired to have that
inner critic voice.
And the reason is this-- that
we all have a very strong safety
instinct.
And the safety instinct
is the part of us
that wants to keep us safe
from harm at any cost.
It's a very old
ancient, reptilian part
of our-- comes from the
reptilian part of our brain
that's always on the
lookout for danger and risk.
And it's trying to
make sure we survive.
That was very useful
when human beings
were faced with a lot of
life-threatening dangers
all the time.
That instinct to look for danger
and go into fight or flight
when we perceive
any possible danger
is still alive in all of us.
And in our modern
time, it doesn't just
fire when there's
a physical threat.
It fires when there's
an emotional threat.
So when we feel an
emotional threat like,
I might really embarrass
myself saying that idea.
I might really bring some
conflict or criticism
if I point out the
elephant in the room
that I see that nobody
is talking about here.
I might fail.
I might be criticized.
Those are all things we
perceive as emotional threats.
And the safety
instinct is saying no.
We gotta avoid all of those.
Let's stay in the comfort zone.
But if every time
you wanted to take
a stretch, a step in your
life or make a change
or do something that
risked emotional harm,
if every time your safety
instinct just said, hi.
I'm your safety instinct.
I don't like that.
I think we should stay
exactly with the status quo.
really safe over here.
Let's not try it.
Let's not speak up,
you would say, no.
I want to.
I have a longing in
me to try that thing.
I want to make this change.
And you would pretty quickly
overrule your safety instinct.
So our safety instincts have
developed a more sophisticated,
more effective
strategy at getting
us to stay in the comfort zone.
Instead of saying, Hi,
I'm your safety instinct,
please don't do that,
the safety instinct says,
you have no idea what
you're talking about.
Who do you think you are?
You're not ready
to say that yet.
Let's go research
it for a few months
first, and then come
back and say it.
And that is an intimidating
enough narrative
to get most of us to stay
in that comfort zone.
So the inner critic
is a strategy
that your safety
instinct is using
to make sure you
don't do things that
raise that risk of
emotional vulnerability
or possible
emotional discomfort.
And the problem is that
just like in a company,
you end up with
a lot of problems
when you have two departments
that don't coordinate at all.
The risk aversion
department in us
never talks to the fulfillment
department or the reward
department.
It doesn't care.
It really doesn't
care if you ever have
a fulfilled day in your life.
It has one mission--
stay in the comfort zone.
So if we listen to it,
that's what happens.
We stay in the comfort zone.
But we miss out on a lot.
And that's what happens when
we listen to our inner critics.
So if we're hardwired for
self-doubt, what do we do?
What do we do about that?
Safety instinct
isn't going anywhere.
Our desire to do
things that have
us risking failure and criticism
also isn't going anywhere.
So the thing we don't try
and do is become confident.
And this is where I am
against all this advice
that women should just become
more confident, that we've
gotta encourage our girls to be
confident, that confidence is
the answer, because I know
that the women who are leading
and risking and speaking
up and excelling
don't feel confident
as they're doing it.
A couple of my favorite
examples of this one
comes from Twyla Tharp, who
is-- how many people have
heard of Twyla Tharp?
She is one of the most famous
choreographers of our time.
She has won about
10 Tony awards.
She has tons of
honorary degrees.
Her work is celebrated
all over the world.
And she says, every time
I start a new dance when
I go into the studio, I am
completely sure that this is
the one where the audience is
going to walk out on opening
night laughing, because
they're going to see my talent
has run out.
Another one of my
favorite examples
comes from Cherry Murray, who
is the dean of engineering
at Harvard.
And she says, every single day
I feel unqualified for my job.
So what's fascinating
about that is
that Twyla Tharp is
doing the dance anyway,
and Terry Murray took
that job and continues
to show up at that job anyway.
And that's the name of the game.
It's how do I hear the
voice of self-doubt?
It's going to be very
loud if you are truly
playing to your potential.
It's going to be
very loud if you're
sharing your voice and
your gifts in the world,
because the safety
instinct doesn't like
the risk that comes with that.
So how do we let it be there and
hear it, but not take direction
from it in just that way
that Cherry Murray and Twyla
Tharp are talking about?
So to do that we need
to one-- know that it's
that voice when it's talking.
Twyla Tharp actually says,
and then I think, oh, there's
that voice again.
It's been there with
me for every dance
I've started to choreograph.
And I know if I
listened to it, I would
stop choreographing entirely.
So hearing the
voice of self-doubt,
recognizing it for what it is.
You can even ask yourself in
the moment, what does my safety
instinct not like about
this situation when
you hear self-doubt.
So if you hear, I'm really just
always been horrible at that.
And I'm going to
totally screw this up,
what does my safety instinct
not like about this situation?
And you'll see it immediately.
Oh, it doesn't like that
I'm going to get feedback
on this that might hurt.
It doesn't like that if I apply
for this, I may get it or not.
And then you can start to
see why the inner critic is
speaking up.
It can also be fun-- just a
few more playful strategies
you can use.
You can create a character
for your inner critic.
So think about if you were going
to give it a personality, what
kind of personality,
what kind of character
personifies it for you.
And then when you
hear that voice,
you can notice it as
coming from that character.
Whether you imagine
that visually or it's
a particular voice.
And that can just
add some lightness.
And you can see the humor
in what it's saying.
And also, it can
help you remember,
that's not the core of me.
The core of me is the
part that has that desire
to fulfill my potential.
You can also even sometimes
imagine it leaving the space
that you're in.
So if you are writing
an important email
and you notice you're
feeling like you're
being very perfectionistic
in the editing of it,
and feeling like it's not
going to come across right,
and you're hearing
a lot of self-doubt
about what you're
saying, to actually
picture that inner critic
voice leaving the room,
or picture the character
leaving the room.
And then come back
to your screen.
OK.
Now it's just me.
Let's go.
And it sounds hard to believe.
But that actually can make
a really powerful difference
for people and how present
that voice is for them.
So noticing the
inner critic voice,
learning to live with it,
not waiting on confidence.
Please do not wait on
confidence for anything
that you're wanting to do.
But rather the answer is,
it's not becoming confident.
It's having a new kind of
relationship with self-doubt.
OK.
So let's move on to a second
topic, which is unhooking
from praise and criticism.
Unhooking from
praise and criticism.
And this is an area
that really surprised me
in my work with women to
see how many of the issues
that people were coming to
coaching with looked like one
thing on the surface, but were
really something else that
had to do with
their relationship
to praise and criticism.
So one of my clients
came with, I've
been working in my
field for 25 years.
I have done really well in it.
But I see this huge problem
with the conventional way things
are approached in my field.
And she worked in domestic
violence prevention
and services.
I see this huge problem.
And I want to start
my own program
with a different approach.
And my job is so demanding.
I'm so over taxed.
I can never get to this thing.
I want a coach to help
me carve out the time
and hold me accountable
so I can make
some movement on this thing.
OK, great.
Well, I didn't know
yet what I know now,
which is time is
never the real issue.
It's maybe the real
issue 0.5% of the time.
But when we delved
a little deeper,
what was clear for
her was she had always
been a star within her field.
She had always gotten a
lot of positive feedback
and excelled in the
conventional way.
And she knew that
this new approach
that she wanted to bring forward
was going to be controversial.
And as someone who had always
been a good student in school
and done well at
work, that move to how
am I going to launch
something that I know
will be controversial?
Can I live with the
criticism and feedback
and the polarized reactions
that are going to come my way,
was really what was
keeping her stuck.
So that's one example.
Another was a woman who works in
management consulting who said,
you know, I love my job.
I love the analysis.
I really like the
work with clients.
But I have been promoted
to this new level.
And now where I am there's a
lot of harsh feedback coming
my way.
Some of it is at this
level the way my colleagues
and I-- the culture of
how we talk to each other,
there's just a lot of criticism.
Some of it is that now when the
client doesn't like something,
I'm the one that's hearing
everything about it.
And I am finding myself so
on such an emotional roller
coaster with that, and
so uncomfortable with it,
that it's keeping me
from liking my job.
So I'm coming to
coaching to figure out
should I change careers?
Or wait.
That doesn't seem
right, because I love
the actual heart of the work.
And so with her,
again, we have to look
at what's this
relationship to criticism
and negative feedback, and
how does that block us.
I have really found that for
every person, and particularly
for women, there
is a point where
we get stopped in our growth
because of our relationship
to praise and criticism.
And that could be we're
avoidant of criticism,
we're seeking of praise.
For some of us it's that we're
avoidant of a lot of praise.
Paradoxically if you grew
up in a culture where you're
supposed to blend in and don't
brag and don't do things,
don't try to be
in the spotlight,
you will unconsciously
or consciously
avoid the things that will
bring a lot of praise.
So that's another way
we can get hooked.
And so part of this
journey to playing bigger
is unhooking from
praise and criticism.
This does affect women in
particular in a few ways.
Certainly, all of
us human beings
were affected by
praise and criticism.
But there are some
interesting dimensions
of how it affects
women in particular.
One is that we know women
get more harsh criticism
than men in the workforce.
And we get more
personal criticism.
Some of you may
have seen the study
that was done by Karen Snyder.
She's a linguist and
a tech entrepreneur.
She did a study looking
at performance reviews
from about 30 tech companies
and analyzing them using
a variety of linguistic tools.
And she found that
not only did women
get a lot more negative feedback
than men in their performance
reviews, but 73% of the
negative feedback that women got
was criticism of
their personality.
And 2% of the negative
feedback that men got
was criticism of a
personality trait.
So this sense of
the feedback we get
is more personal, and
therefore more wounding for us,
of course, and more
become something
that we're more
alert on avoiding,
there's a real gender gap there
in the kind of feedback we get.
So of course, as a
result of that, we're
going to feel more hooked,
more caught up in what's
going on with the
negative feedback we get.
Another interesting factor
that has a gender dimension
is what I call the "noisy room."
And I call it the noisy
room because I always
felt when I was working
inside a large organization,
if I was in a meeting with
15 people around a conference
table, that room felt
incredibly noisy to me
with the cues and the dynamics
of everything that was going on
amongst that group.
So when people were talking,
I would be noticing well
that person really seems
to be resisting everything
that person's saying.
And that person's in a
really grumpy mood today.
And that person is
always just trying
to win over these people.
All those dynamics.
Very, very full of information.
And I found that for me,
that often sometimes got
in the way of my ability
to really push forward
in the midst of complex dynamics
and kind of see the main event,
or let those dynamics just be.
And let the project go forward
without feeling like they
needed to be resolved.
So I had noticed that
in myself, and noticed
that I didn't see some
of my male colleagues
grappling with all
of-- they weren't
even aware of the things
I was talking about.
If I had to bring them
up to be resolved,
often they weren't even aware.
And they certainly didn't think
they needed to be resolved.
And so then I was
really intrigued
when I read that there's
research that supports exactly
what that experience was.
One-- that there is
a gender difference
in the amount of information
that women and men pick up
in non-verbal cues.
There's very few
gender differences
that actually are consistently
borne out by the research.
One of them that there's a
pretty solid body of studies
around is that women pick
up a lot more information
from facial expressions,
from body language.
And so if you think
about what that means,
it means we're
processing a lot more.
And that includes
people's reactions to us.
We're processing a lot more of
people's subtle reactions to us
than our male counterparts are.
And that's something that
can be distracting for us.
This particular
study done at Harvard
also found that contrary
to all that research
on emotional the benefits of
high emotional intelligence--
there's also some downsides
of high emotional intelligence
around morale and productivity.
So I think it really speaks
to what I'm talking about.
If you have very high
emotional intelligence,
you're picking up
all those cues.
It can interfere with a
certain kind of productivity.
You may feel kind of
down about the dynamics
you're observing that other
people aren't even noticing.
So that's another way we can
get hooked on people's reactions
to us.
We just get more information
about that as women.
We're oblivious to less.
And that can be
helpful, but we have
to be really discerning
about when it's helpful
and when it's not.
And then lastly,
another factor that
informs our relationship to
feedback is our history, again.
That if you think
about women's history,
for most of our
history, women could not
survive through financial
power, political power,
physical strength.
We didn't have those things.
Right?
We weren't going to be
able to survive or ensure
the survival of our dearest
ones through physical might,
through political rights,
through legal protection,
through financial
ownership of property.
We didn't have any
of those things.
And our primary survival
strategy-- or you
could also say our
primary strategy
for thriving-- was social
influence and likability.
Working through
relationships to do what
would be approved
of or tolerable
or met with a positive reaction.
And the reason
that's so important
is because for a
lot of us there's
a kind of legacy of
that that still lives
where conflict or
harsh criticism
really does feel
life-threatening,
really can feel
life-threatening if we really
tune into our inner
experience of it.
And that's why.
So how do we unhook from
praise and criticism?
There are a bunch of
strategies in the book.
There's one I want to focus
on today, which is changing
your story about feedback.
And the new story that I
want to offer you today
is a little bit-- it
sounds a little bit
radical to some people at first.
So hang in there with me.
And it's this.
That feedback never tells
you anything about yourself.
It can only tell you about the
person giving the feedback.
So I'm guessing this is a pretty
feedback-oriented culture.
Yes?
We have to take
feedback very seriously.
It's going to help us grow.
It's key to our development.
It's integral.
Something great
leaders are always
looking for a lot of feedback.
So to say feedback can
never tell any tell you
anything about you, it can
only tell you about the people
you're getting
feedback from, kind of
seems like it flies
in the face of that.
So let's talk about
that for a minute.
So let's say your
manager says you're
really great with details
and project management.
But, there's something missing
in the sort of team interaction
and the ability to
motivate people and make
them feel comfortable, kind
of on the soft skills side,
there's something missing.
So that's the feedback.
So what does that
tell us about you?
Does that tell us you're
a good project manager?
Does that tell us
there's something missing
in the soft skills side?
Does it tell us any
facts about that?
Really, when you think about it?
The only fact we're
actually getting there
is the fact of that is the
feedback my manager gave me.
That sounds like
that's the feedback.
That is his or her perception,
his or her experience
of my work.
That's the fact.
That's his or her
experience of my work.
What if your whole
team says, you're
a really great project manager,
great with the details.
But we all feel kind of
like we can't connect,
we're not really
motivated by you.
Does that give us
any facts about you?
Does that give us some facts
about that group of people?
Perhaps some facts about
what's coming across to them,
tells us about their
experience of you.
So the next step there is
not to dismiss the feedback.
This is not, oh,
that's all about them.
So I'm going to ignore it.
It's oh, that's
giving me information
about these individuals.
And if these are
people that I want
to work with
effectively, if these
are important stakeholders
to what I'm doing,
I'm going to really
listen to that feedback.
I'm going to try and understand
what it is telling me about
them, what they need from
me, what they expect of me,
what they expect of
someone in this role,
what works for them
and what doesn't.
And if I want to work
with them effectively,
I may incorporate or adapt
with some of that feedback.
So the power of
that is that when
we're looking at feedback as,
that's information about them,
we don't get defensive.
You never have to decide
if it's true or not.
You never have to
call your friend
and talk about how crazy your
manager is or what they said,
because it really doesn't
matter whether it's
true in some objective
sense or not.
What matters is you're
getting information
about someone who potentially
is an important stakeholder
for you.
And when we're not
taking it personally,
when we're not making
the feedback about us,
something interesting happens.
We start to get really
curious about the feedback,
because it's not personal.
We're not defending against it.
Oh.
Interesting.
Hm.
They think I'm not
connecting with people.
I would love to
understand more like what
is their vision of
what that looks like?
Or how do they see that
fitting into my job?
Where would that happen
in the flow of my work?
We can ask a lot of questions.
We can learn more.
We can be truly open.
And then we can adapt and
incorporate the feedback,
but from the
perspective of, that's
what it takes to
be effective here.
Not from the
perspective of, there's
something defective about me.
And that is so important for
us, particularly for women,
for people of color,
because the feedback we get
is often going to
be impacted by bias.
And we don't want to take
that on and make it about us.
We want to allow it to be
looked at more neutrally,
and with more curiosity.
What is this telling
me about what
it takes to be effective
in this context?
So thoughts, questions on
anything we talked about today?
And this is a great
time-- I always
say this is a great time to not
listen to your inner critic,
take that first
step of if you hear
the voice in your head
saying, that question
does-- I know it's not well
thought out enough yet.
Or it might not be
a good question.
Or maybe she said that and
I wasn't gonna catch it.
That's your inner critic.
So this is a great
opportunity to practice
not listening to that voice.
AUDIENCE: While women may
receive more negative feedback
about their more
personal attributes,
that they may get actually
less useful critical feedback
about things they can do to grow
that men in the same position
do.
So yeah.
If you have any thoughts on
that, and maybe strategies
for getting more of
that kind of feedback.
TARA MOHR: Yeah.
Yeah.
And I'm not sure if
you're referring--
there was one
study that came out
last fall about the feedback
that women get tends to be
more general and more vague.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
TARA MOHR: Yeah.
Yeah.
Exactly.
Just that it's another really
important thing to be aware of.
I think for men
and women, knowing
these trends are so
important, because it
means if you look at
your performance review,
you can say, oh.
A lot of this feedback
is personality-driven.
There's nothing specific
here that's tied
to the core objectives
for my role.
OK.
That's not just me.
I know that's part
of a larger pattern.
And that's potentially
then something
you might want to ask
for more specifically.
If you're in the kind
of team or department
where you can have a
constructive discussion
outside of specific
performance reviews,
like circulate those articles,
and make sure everybody who's
giving and receiving
performance reviews
is aware of those patterns
so they can catch themselves
in them.
I spoke at a company
a few years ago,
and was talking about the
personality feedback thing
and talking about
the word abrasive,
and how abrasive--
you know, it's
very commonly used with women.
It's never used with men.
And there was a male executive
in the audience who said,
I just used that word in
three performance reviews
last week with three women.
And now I realize I
need to go change it.
So I think raising the
awareness there is huge,
and then asking for
more specific feedback,
and feedback around
your objectives
for your job is really important
if you see that's happening
in your reviews.
AUDIENCE: One thing that
I think a lot of women
at Google all struggle with,
because tech can be a very,
very male-dominated world.
And I personally work
in sales at Google.
So business is also a
fairly male-dominated world,
is that there's this constant
conflict between discomfort
in the situation that you're
in, and wanting to improve it,
and wanting to make
sure that people
are educated about implicit
bias and all that good stuff.
But at the same time,
yearning for a community
where that doesn't
have to be explained,
that it's already understood.
So in your experience
coaching, did you
ever find women that were also
dealing with that dichotomy?
And how did you coach
them through it?
TARA MOHR: Yeah.
I would just say I think
that's a really important need.
I would go further than
to say it's a want.
It's a need to have that
kind of like-minded community
or community where you
feel like you're not--
you don't have to be in change
agent mode and navigating
how exactly do I be a diplomatic
change agent all the time.
And that can happen
in a lot of ways.
It could happen with women
inside your organization,
if there's an
opportunity for that.
It is the reason that I think
a lot of women do things
that even our cross industry--
whether that's a group coaching
experience or some other
kind of self-formed women's
group, or a book club that
talks about these issues,
or whatever.
It's just so tremendously
nourishing for people.
And I would really
encourage you to create
that whatever way you can.
AUDIENCE: What was the
most challenging pushback
you experienced in trying
to play big and speak up?
TARA MOHR:
Personally, or-- yeah.
That's a great question.
Well, I'm writing a lot
of political pieces now.
So that's interesting.
I get some pushback around that.
And for me, it's usually around
political or social issues.
And that's definitely a
playing big edge for me
that I still grapple with,
like, how much am I really
willing to speak out about
what I perceive as happening
in our collective milieu.
And yeah.
I just find the more radical
I get with that, the more
pushback I get.
So it's a good playing
big edge for me.
And I think we're always
on this journey of what's
my playing big edge now?
What feels really scary but
important now that doesn't end?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: In terms of
educating those around us-- so
the men in the room--
especially when they're
in very senior
leadership positions,
and you can see certain
characteristics and behaviors
kind of trickle through
all of the layers.
I mean, coming to talks
like this is fantastic.
But how do we help bring
that message outward?
TARA MOHR: Yeah.
So the interesting thing is that
I believe that education really
needs to happen for
everyone, and not just
women for themselves.
But women for how they manage
and work with other women.
For example, the research
on the double bind
that women are often perceived
as competent or likable,
but not both.
That phenomenon is worse
with a female manager
than a male manager.
And a lot of times
there is a kind
of policing that women have
done of their own voices,
or their own
expression, or whatever
they had to compartmentalize
on the way up, that
really makes it hard for them
to fully support other women.
So I think it's really
important to think
of the education
and the conversation
as needing to
happen for everyone.
And it's tricky,
because with leaders--
and I would say even
particularly with female
leaders-- the most important
thing is that they're doing
their own playing big
work, because you really
can't support-- as a woman,
you cannot, you will not,
end up supporting in another
woman what you are not allowing
in yourself.
So if you're
walking on eggshells
with the way you
express your voice,
you really don't want a
direct report who's not.
That's not going to
go over well, right?
So that.
And I think that's really
important for everyone
to reflect on.
How do I do my own
playing big work,
knowing that it's going to
change my ability to embrace
and support others' ambitions?
That's more effective than
receiving an education.
SPEAKER 1: Thank you, everyone.
TARA MOHR: Thank you, everyone.
SPEAKER 1: That's
all we have today.
TARA MOHR: Thank you.